we have been warned that this eruption
could last till december it's spewing
out hot lava behind me all our life is
there
we've built it
with our hands the island of la palma in
spain's canary islands has been
transformed by the eruption of a volcano
there are people who are not going to
find their house after this because it's
five seven eight meters under the ground
so what now for the island
experts have said the aftermath of the
volcanic eruption could last for up to
84 days or almost three months that
calculation is based on the length of
previous eruptions in the archipelago
for people here they've been hugely
affected by this but for many people
this is considered a bit of a spectacle
it's extraordinary to see something like
this the last time this happened was 50
years ago
[Music]
it is spewing out this hot molten rock
some of it those giant boulders are
flinging up a thousand feet into the air
and we're out four miles away but you
can hear at times those ginormous
explosions and that lava that hot lava
is coming straight from the core of the
earth and exploding into the sky whilst
incredibly hot the lava is very slow
moving giving people plenty of time to
escape its spread the police came that
we had to go we had to go we had to go
and
we left everything we put the suitcases
in and we left our house but it's the
way the lava interacts with the
environment that makes it dangerous the
volcano has been spewing out up to ten
thousand five hundred tons of sulfur
dioxide every day
that gas reacts with oxygen and moisture
in the atmosphere causing acid rain
volcanic ash can also irritate the eyes
and lungs
so far the levels of toxic gases are not
dangerous for humans
some experts say the lava could
eventually meet the sea the 1 000 degree
celsius melted rock can cause explosions
as it touches the water as well as
producing clouds of toxic gas
trees homes and roads surrounding the
volcano have been engulfed by the
streams of lava at least 350 houses have
been entombed and over 400 acres are
buried and banana plantations schools
and infrastructure are severely damaged
and whilst many people already some 7
000 people have been displaced from
their homes and been evacuated many more
could face the same fate if that volcano
continues to erupt
as the lava has slowed it's grown
thicker rising up to 15 meters high in
some places
the head of the canary islands
government has said he will request
funding to rebuild roads water pipes and
create temporary accommodation for
families who have lost their homes and
their farmland
there are people who are not going to
find their house after this because it's
five seven eight meters under the ground
people there are people here who have
been here for all their life they have
grown here they have their sons here
so it's quite hard for them to leave the
house because of a volcano
over time plants and trees will return
to the area in a process known as
ecological succession
but this can take decades
the plan now is really to try and help
those families they're in temporary
accommodation but the land that their
homes were once on cannot be rebuilt
that is going to be a huge
huge task for those families but also
the local government here as they try
and figure out what to do next meanwhile
that volcano continues to erupt
[Music]